who is better Backstreet Boys or NSYNC
that's a rough question quora and
whoever wrote This what I would say is I
know the Backstreet Boys
a lot better than I know the NSYNC boys
but I know Timberlake particularly well
I play golf for Justin Timberlake
there's the biggest name drop of all
time everyone's just gonna think I'm an
songs wise I mean they're in my
head they're like equal
hit for hit I don't I don't want to
choose I can't put my neck on the line
for this one because I love Backstreet
Boys and I know Timberlake very well but
don't know the NSYNC boys they both have
an equal level of hit so I'm not
answering full reviews
foreign